what is yoga Oh obviously everyone knows
Yoga comes from India yeah for me yoga
is as appealing as watching paint dry
yeah I can name a few yoga positions
there's like the downward dog I know a
bit about yoga I'm just a lazy sack of
[ __ ] so I don't do it there are so many
different definitions of what yoga is
traditionally speaking yoga is Sanskrit
for yoke which is also translated to
Union inhale inhale and that's what this
is gonna look like when you like
traditionally understand what the Sun
Salutation is exhale and you're going to
bed
[Music]
[Music]
like I feel like the first step into an
exorcism I'm gonna be in pain
tomorrow feel like I'm gonna be in pain
I feel like I'm just gonna be in
constant pain for the next two months
my back hurts so much like so much
[Music]
I like we've been doing this two weeks
feels like forever Yoga is actually kind
of fun and I think that's partly because
we're in these classes with a bunch of
our colleagues who we know and like the
thing that caught me off-guard the most
about yoga was the rage I was
experiencing the first week in my body's
total rejection of the practice so is
doing a good job of like not feeling
that rage that I was feeling a lot in
the beginning but now today I came back
in full force and I was swearing the
most challenging pose is anything where
I have to go across my body because to
be honest yoga with big boobs is a
little more challenging I think I feel
better so far like my body isn't totally
rebelling against me at all hours of the
day which is a change two weeks in I
don't think there's been that much of a
change in my body I think people get
discouraged really easily when they
begin you have to want to do it you have
to really want to learn you have to
really have an open mind and if you've
never done yoga you don't really have
that opened mind yet you so you need to
begin to develop it
I feel all right yoga's fine
yoga feels like a drag before it starts
and then after it's done I'm like yeah
it was pretty good we're halfway through
I feel great
I've only been doing this for a month
and I can already see the changes I'm
getting better I'm getting more flexible
I'm getting stronger I can see it
the results are real
[Music]
Henry hates the chanting but I really
like the chanting in yoga
chanting uh that's it's something we do
I'm not connected with the chanting I'm
not connecting to the spirituality of it
in a lot of ways I can't help but have a
really stupid grin on my face we close
your eyes but I'm smiling the whole time
you're home hive it I don't know the
words it's just not really my thing I
like that I'm doing this you know bring
your arms a little closer together if I
were to go somewhere by myself I don't
think I would feel comfortable doing
that
who my favorite posture
[Music]
and I just lay down on my back now when
we started this I was like here and like
I was burning it now I know it just
feels like a good stretch I'm not gonna
answer questions what I do it [ __ ]
so I decided it was time to go to the
chiropractor
we took an x-ray turns out I have
[ __ ] scoliosis what do this that's my
spine right there that's like where all
my pain is I was like in a weird way I'm
like really relieved to know that like
I'm not crazy and like I actually have a
thing that we now know and I can fix and
like I asked him what should I do
you said yoga I'm glad I'm doing these
classes because I would have never taken
it upon myself to go to yoga classes
starting now in this environment with my
co-workers is probably the best way to
go because we're all just having fun and
joking with each other next week I don't
know what we're doing that oh god that
terrifies me I'm walking down to my
first non buzzfeed yoga class in my life
this waves have been in years we did
[ __ ] I've never done before it was
probably not the worst person there but
I was definitely bottom five
there's no way
ever pay for yoga there's definitely
like new laughing it was not a fun class
there was this guy with a man bun next
to me he seemed to know exactly what he
was doing it did not like being next to
him at all there's like a reminder that
like oh yeah just doing two months of
yoga is like a drop in the bucket and
what it takes to actually be getting
yoga I'm ready to keep doing this and
become a full-blown yogi I don't like
saying that it sounds gross that's a
really relative question like I still
don't feel like I have a fully grounded
yoga practice and I've been 10 years
plus in now for other people it could
take months I already kind of miss doing
yoga I don't know how much you captured
her on film there was just like such a
fun atmosphere for like any kind of
workout class there's lots of laughing
there's lots of jokes there's nothing
give and take here's the thing
I thought yoga was something a little
different than yoga turns out to be I
think the biggest misconception of yoga
is that it's easy and I think Yoga has
helped me address the things I'm unhappy
about I don't do physical activity
unless I have to do it and yoga is
definitely a physical activity I've been
in pain and I was like I'm just like out
of shape ha but no I have a [ __ ]
curve in my back look at that I'm
important to be traffic I assume you're
gonna put it
yeah the best Percy
[Music]
you
it's easy you have to push yourself to
make it hard again and that's kind of
down
[Music]